question is will he have the offensive
the scoring skill set shooting LeBron
James takes his time and measures in
slowing the drum take another time tap
bike Robert LeBron wide open down low
for - that was a nifty pass from junior
I'm over the top rope was a coach down
on this LeBron James just to the goal
LeBron had that shoulder in position he
knew he had the shot straight to the
hoop all trying to crunch charge they
make that posted LeBron was deep going
at Simmons is 14 the defendants think he
was going to pass it and then he trips
up the shot LeBron James with a nice
steel touch the books on the rule not to
do for Fox here at Johnson look at the
strength here
[Applause]
pocket pick by Jose Calderon up to the
task how about that crowd of running
sneaky no LeBron James has it got you
back that's assigned to it I'm not
better
LeBron against citizens using his length
give us some space though he is back
about two inches there and it came to
brown the green like LeBron hang in
there and hit it to the square now
there's Brian the two men screen what's
the switch LeBron backs up for three
enough gas in the tank LeBron losses
inside goodness it heavy traffic plus he
gives the animal iron and in throws bump
right there but from the hind still
shoots it to the